[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yo
dawg i heard you like dreams so put your
dream within a dream within a dream
so inception has just passed its 10-year
anniversary
and with 10 it apparently coming out
soon i thought i'd take another look at
the film
to break down all of the cool little
details in it there will be heavy
spoilers here
so if you've been living in a dream
world and haven't had a chance to check
it out yet then i highly recommend that
you turn off now
if you enjoy the video then please drop
a thumbs up and make sure you subscribe
to the channel for breakdowns like this
every day
without the way welcome to the heavy
spoilers show i'm your host definition
now let's get into our breakdown of
inception
okay so let's start at the top so
inception has an ambiguous ending
that at the time left every viewer
debating whether the main character cobb
had returned to the real world
or if he was actually still stuck in a
dream it's something that fans have gone
back and forth over for the past decade
but nolan actually did drop a specific
clue in the movie that confirmed cobb
made it home to his family throughout
the film whenever the character is in a
dream he can be seen wearing his wedding
ring
this is because his wife mallory is very
much alive whenever he's in a sedated
state
and thus he doesn't want to quite cast
away the memory of her
this is probably a theory that you've
seen dotted about on the internet before
as it's been around for a while now
however one thing that i haven't seen
discussed very much
centers around cobb's totem throughout
the entire movie we are told that the
spinning top is actually his totem
and that this is what he uses to assess
whether he's in the real world or not
i actually don't believe that this is
the case at all and i think that he
simply tells everyone that it is
because he's so paranoid cobb clearly
struggles with grasping reality in the
first place and i feel like he's the
kind of character that will keep his
true totem to himself
we're told in the film that no one
should touch anyone else's totem
and that doing so can cause issues the
spinning top itself
also belonged to mal so it is unlikely
that cobb would actually use it
especially due to how much the character
infects his dreams
the fact that we know the wedding ring
indicates what's real and what isn't
to me tells us that the ring is actually
what cobb's totem is
if he's wearing it he knows he's in a
dream and if he's not he knows he's in
reality
which is far more trustworthy than a
spinning top cobb does spin this at the
end of the movie
but upon seeing his family's faces he
goes to them instead
allowing it to spin without even seeing
the outcome doing this
pretty much invalidates the spin showing
that he simply doesn't care about the
result
because he already knows the truth the
cool little easter eggs don't stop there
either
and if you take the first letter of all
of the characters names in the movie
and rearrange them they actually spell
out the words dreams pay
the movie itself is of course about a
crew that makes money from carrying out
heists and dreams
and thus dreams pay this is because of
dom
robert eames arthur mal saito
peter ariadne and yusef the names also
have specific meanings
behind them as cobb was actually the
name of a thief in nolan's first film
the following
it also means dream in sanskrit and on
top of this
it could be seen as meaning cobweb which
is of course a trap laid out by a spider
cobb pretty much traps people in mazes
and webs throughout the movie
so i definitely think it ties in with
this ariadne is actually from ancient
myths
and the name comes from the story the
minotaur and the labyrinth
this is also fitting as she's a
character that builds maces too
yusef is the arabic version of joseph
someone who interpreted the pharaoh's
dreams in the bible
and fisher may actually come from the
stories of king arthur
in the myths fish's kingdom changed due
to the wounds that were inflicted upon
him and throughout the film we see as
the locations change depending on his
mind state
now as for the story and its many easter
eggs we open
unsure of exactly what's going on with
cobb washing up on the shore
nolan stated that he wanted the movie
itself to feel like a dream for the
viewer
in that we didn't really have any idea
how he got there
the credits of the movie reflect this
too and the title text inception
appears three times at the end of the
film this is meant to represent the
three layers
and as we watch the text pop up we are
coming further out of the dream that the
movie has taken us through
cobb is taken to saito's palace which we
learned the character actually
constructed for him
earlier in the movie so that he could
carry out a heist as we learn
every structure within the dreamers
subconscious can exist down there
so it makes a lot of sense how this
location was carried across
we're then introduced to mal as she
looks over the edge of a balcony
something that teases how the character
died in real life
you also see a picture by francis bacon
hanging up in the back of a room
this was actually created by the artist
to remember his lover
who sadly died the painting is very much
a representation of bacon
trying to hold on to his lover's memory
but how he's created a twisted version
of them
much like how cop has with his late wife
cobb goes about stealthily killing the
projections in cytosubconscious
and though his gun has a silencer on it
he puts his hand
over it to catch the cartridge as it
ejects in order to not make any extra
sounds
cobb gets the secrets but is caught by
saito who was informed of what they were
doing by mal
now mal is an extension of cobb there's
actually a cool little moment here
which gives that away when sido
discovers that cobb has managed to steal
his secrets
mal can actually be seen smiling for a
split second
showing she's happy he got away with it
we learn about dreams within dreams
and are also introduced to the song non
non-genoric retriene
a slow down version of the song is
actually used at the beginning of the
movie
when we see cobb waking up on the shore
frank sinatra did a play on this for his
infamous song
my way but there's a lot going on in the
original version
that hints towards the psychology of
cobb the song is actually about having
no regrets and leaving the past behind
something that the protagonist refuses
to do
because of his wife's death cobb even
has an elevator that provides access to
floors
filled with regret so it's clear that
he's got a lot he would like to change
however at the end he finally lets go
and reunites with his family
shedding the idea of her which has held
him back throughout the film
this all ties in with the song and is
possible that
cobb could even be the job himself and
the mission is actually to try and wake
him up and get him to come back to
reality
but that's a topic for another video
michael kane aka miles does hint at this
and yeah let me know if you'd like me to
discuss it in more detail
after the job goes to crap they wake up
on board the train
and cobb leaves as quickly as he can
he's told to just find another carriage
but he gets off the ride completely
after saying that he doesn't like trains
in the movie we learn that he and his
wife used to trying to kill themselves
in the deeper levels of their
subconsciousness
so that they could wake up cobb is
clearly tormented by trains
and one actually shows up repeatedly
throughout the movie at very awkward
moments
so yeah he really doesn't like them the
train carries the number
3502 on it and we discover that this was
the room number that he and his wife
spent their anniversary in at a hotel
another number which reappears
throughout the film is 528491
fisher comes up with this randomly but
it later appears as the blonde lady from
westworld's phone number
it's also broken up to be part of the
rooms that the teams stay in
the top room is 528 and the room
directly below it that arthur sets
explosives in
is 491 yikes in the finale fischer also
opens the safe with the code
528491 so yeah it appears throughout the
film
now if this hasn't blown your mind then
you should also know that hashtag
528491 can be used as a hex color code
to display the shade of cyan
which was used on a lot of branding in
the movie
wow yeah that that's the noise of every
graphic designer's head exploding
now from here cobb goes to miles and is
introduced to ariadne
cobb puts it through her paces and gets
her to design a maze
initially he gives her a notepad with a
grid on it she draws a rectangular maze
but fails time and time again clearly
the grids are holding her back
and thus she flips the notepad around
and draws the maze on the back of the
pad
where there's no lines to distract her
cobb also can't tear this out because it
makes for the base of the book
and thus you've got them there are nate
you bloody got him
now when planning out how they're gonna
carry out the heist they spend the
majority of the scenes in the dream
world
this is because time works differently
in a dream and
using the time dilation that's present
within the realities they have a lot
longer to plan out the mission
we also meet eems who is a forger and
when we
first come across the character he's
gambling and actually loses his hand
however he still goes up with a full
stack of chips
likely meaning that they're fake this is
hindered out by cobb picking one up
and aims saying that his forgery goes
far beyond handwriting
we also meet yusef who works with
chemicals and sedatives
you might notice his cat climbing around
and licking the pot beside him
and the next time we see it it's asleep
so we can kind of guess what was in that
slowly they put it all together and
bought the same plane as fisher
which is charted by saito cobb orders a
water
which fisher then gets too and this
gives cod the opportunity to sedate him
as he takes the first glass and then
passes it forward
you could say he in intercepted the
drink
i'm here all week thank you now a cool
little detail that all of the cars have
is their own stake motto in this reality
normally american cars have state mottos
so you can tell where they're from but
in inception
the phrase across all of them is the
alternate state
the alternate state is of course a
reference to dreams
which are often classed as you guessed
it in alternate state
they then take fishy to a safe house and
i love how when eems is adopting his
browning disguise
you can slowly see him changing in the
mirrors on the dressing table
after fish's subconscious descends on
the location the group flee to a bridge
whilst they go further into their
target's mind a cool little moment
happens when yusuf actually sticks his
middle finger up to fish's forces
right before he drives off the bridge
that's a bit of a blink and you'll miss
a moment but
it's really cool and i spotted it
because i've done it to a couple of
people myself
the group arrive at the hotel valle
finero which we can see written on a
napkin
edward de valle finero was allegedly a
con man
who put together a group that stole the
mona lisa in 1911.
he wished to make copies of it to sell
him off to six buyers
but the group were caught and the
painting was returned in 1913.
there's actually no evidence that
eduardo existed
so this is a cool little easter egg for
the name of the hotel
and also the heist that he carried out
is very similar to the one that these
are trying they trick fisher into going
further into the dream with them
whilst arthur stays behind to set up the
kick
this starts one of the best scenes in
film history and i don't even care
that hallway fight still looks
incredible now the lack of gravity
provided a lot of challenge for the
filmmakers
namely with ellen page's hair and how it
would move
thus nolan solved this by just tying a
hair up in a bun to stop it moving about
in the rooms we can also see certain
things floating around
except for the duvets on the bed hotel
duvets are normally tucked in very
tightly
so this is a nice little bit of
attention to detail the way that the
scenes are edited are also very similar
to a technique to what nolan would later
use in dunkirk
the top level scenes time lengthwise are
shorter than the middle
which are in turn shorter than the
bottom level so
just as time gets longer the further
down we go in the levels
the length of the scenes do too now in
the i space
i want to call it it's very similar to
the james bond movie on a majesty's
secret service
nolan actually said that this was his
favorite bond movie so it's great to see
him paying homage here
and hopefully hopefully one day he gets
to direct one too
they infiltrate the base but mal
unfortunately shows up
and intercepts their plans no one is
actually able to warn fisher
because before he enters the complex
from the pipes
his radio cackles up and he turns it off
they enter the subconscious that cobin
mal built
in order to rescue fisher whilst arthur
moves the bodies about
i love how he had to tie them up in
order to transport them around the hotel
and he even closes the briefcase before
things go zero g
so that the equipment inside it doesn't
go floating around everywhere
in the third layer cobb expresses his
guilt over the spinning top within
mild's mind
as this made her lose a grip on reality
this is where it's once more confirmed
that mal's totem was the top
and thus it does add a lot of weight to
our theory at the start of the video
now i have seen people say that cobb was
a bad dude for doing this
however all he was trying to do was make
mal realize that the reality they built
was well not real however this inception
worked too well
and upon exiting the dream world she
started to question
everything so yeah cobb wasn't a bad guy
but it was his fault that mal died
now cobb sends ariadne and fisher up to
the top level
and travels to saito which is what we
see in the opening of the movie
because saito died before fischer and
the others in the upper layer
he's been down there for much longer and
has aged considerably
it's also possible that the entire movie
has all just been a flashback
of cobs sat like this at the table and
this is kind of why we cut back to it
instantly at the beginning
in dreams you can often go through time
and to a different location
instantaneously
and it is possible that cobb himself is
sort of daydreaming about what led to
this moment as he remembers it
fisher comes face to face with his
father who gives him the windmill that
we saw the young robert have as a child
and thus the idea that he should go on a
different path to his father
is planted within his mind cobb rescues
saito who makes the call to allow him
throughout the border
and thus he gets to go home to his
family now there's not much going on in
the scene
but on the table we can see a small
little building made out of blocks
cobb's son even says we're building a
house on a cliff
hinting that he may follow in his
father's footsteps as an
architect
either way it doesn't matter as he gets
a happy ending
and to be with his family it is possible
that this entire movie was actually just
an inception
carried out by his friends to finally
get him to let go of his wife
but as i said another time another video
maybe next week let's see anyway that's
our breakdown
i know we didn't hit everything in the
movie as there's just so much more to
talk about but
make sure you comment below and let us
know if you think there's anything that
should have been added
if you want something else to watch then
make sure you check out our breakdown of
joker which is going to be linked at the
end
we go over the coolest little details in
that film so it's definitely worth
checking out if you want to know more
every month on the 15th we give away
free blu-rays and all you have to do to
be on the chance of winning the mcu
infinity soccer box set is leave a like
and subscribe with notifications on if
you want to support the channel and get
to see content early then please
consider clicking the join button below
you can also come chat to us on our
discord server or at heavyspoilers on
twitter
if not then thank you for staying until
the end of the video i've been
definition
you've been the best and i'll see you
next time take care
peace and he woke up and it was all a
[Music]
dream
you